>> GOOD EVENING, EVERYONE,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ALWAYS THE SAME, THE MEN BECOME
WEAK AND WE HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE CURRENCY GETS DEVALUED
AND THE REASON WE HAVE SOCIETY
IN THE FIRST PLACE IS TO PROTECT
THE WEAK FROM THE STRONG.
THAT IS WHERE YOU HAVE A
SOCIETY.
AND IN PLACES LIKE THIS AND YOU
JUST CAN'T GO WHERE YOU WANT TO
GO.
LEGITIMATE AUTHORITY AND THEROAE
POLICE, THEY ARE CONTROLLED BY
ARMED PREDATORS AND THEY TAKE
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT BECAUSE
THEY CAN AND THIS IS AN ANCIENT
PROBLEM.
IT USED TO BE CALLED A HIGHWAY
ROBBERY.
FOR MOST OF HISTORY AND CAP
PEOPLE CLOSE TO HOME.
IT TURNS OUT IT STILL EXISTS,
BUT NOW IT'S CALLED CARJACKING.
AND IT IS THE CLEAREST POSSIBLE
SIGN THAT THE CIVILIZATION IS
FALLING APART.
>> NOBODY'S GOING TO BUILD BACK
ANYTHING AND A CITY WITH THIS,
MOST PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO DO
HERE AND CARJACKING IS NOW A
PERMANENT FEATURE OF LIFE.
>> DEMANDING THAT SHE HANDLED
EVERYTHING SHE HAD INCLUDING HER
CAR, AND THAT IS A CARJACKING
THAT IS ALWAYS AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO GIVE UP
THEIR CARS.
THE MAJORITY OF VICTIMS ARE OLD
WOMEN, YOUNG WOMEN, AND THAT IS
WHERE THE PEOPLE WHO DO IT WOULD
DO ANYTHING, IF YOU WOULD STEAL
SOMEONE'S CAR AT GUNPOINT.
AND THE MOST BASIC LEVEL AND
THEY HAVE EVER POSTED.
IN THIS CASE THAT WAS CERTAINLY
TRUE, AND IT ALLOWED THEM TO DO
THE SAME TO OTHER WOMEN IN THE
CITY, A LOT OF THEM.
AND IT WAS A CAR BLOCKING THEM
IN, THE NEXT THING THERE IS A
GUN BARREL IN MY FACE AND HE WAS
LIKE GET OUT OF THE CAR, GET OUT
OF THE CAR.
AND IN THE CITY THAT PROBABLY
NEEDS ABOUT 2000, THEY ARE UNDER
500 ACTIVE DUTY POLICEMAN LEFT
IN NEW ORLEANS.
THEY HAVE DEFINITELY DEFUNDED
THE POLICE.
BUT IN THIS CASE AND IT WAS
ULTIMATELY CAUGHT AND TRIED AND
CONVICTED AND SENTENCED AND SO
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY SHOWED UP
TO THE SENTENCING.
BUT HERE IS
THE VICTIMS.
THE WOMEN HAVE BEEN TERRORIZED
BY THIS PREDATOR.
AND LETTING THEM KNOW WHO WHOSE
SIDE SHE WAS ON.
>> THE MAYOR SHOWED UP AS A
CHARACTER WITNESS DURING
SENTENCING.
ROBBING THREE WOMEN IN SEPARATE
INCIDENTS WITH A FAKE GUN,
FEELING THAT IT'S A BELONGING,
SAYING THEY WERE TRAUMATIZED BY
WHAT HAPPENED AND THEN THEY FELT
VICTIMIZED ALL OVER AGAIN WHEN
THE MAYOR SHOWED UP IN SUPPORT
OF THE YOUNG CRIMINALS.
>> I WAS IN SHOCK AND SHE WAS
THERE FOR THE MOTHER AND IT FELT
LIKE SHE WAS SUPPORTING THE
CRIME.
>> THE JUVENILE JUDGE SENTENCED
IT TO A THREE YEAR SUSPENDED
SENTENCE.
AND IT IS AN OPEN AREA WHERE
THEY GOT TO BE DESTROYED IN AN
ALREADY WOUNDED CITY.
AND THEY HAVE A CONNECTION TO
THIS CARJACKING.
ONE OF THE WELFARE PROGRAMS AND
.
>> AND GIVING THE CRIMINALS AS
MUCH SUPPORT AS THEY NEED IS
WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE
DOING.
GIVING THEM THE ABILITY TO
COMMIT MORE CRIMES AS POSSIBLE.
SO WHY WOULD THEY DO SOMETHING
LIKE THIS?
WHY WOULD THEY FORCE PEOPLE TO
PAY ALL THE TAXES OF ALL COLORS?
WELL, PROBABLY BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LEFT TEND TO BE
THE ONES WHO VOTE FOR YOU.
AND SO IT'S HAPPENING IN A LOT
OF PLACES.
THE DOWNSIDE IS IT LEADS TO
CARNAGE.
A TOTAL OF 177 AND THIS IS TRUE
AND A LOT OF OTHER PLACES AS
WELL, PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF
18, THE LOCALS STATION FOUND
THAT IN 2021 AND SOMETIMES THEY
ARE FATAL.
IN MARCH THEY MUTILATED THE BODY
OF A GRANDMOTHER AS A CARJACK OR
DRAG HER BODY DOWN THE STREET.
>> THESE 15-YEAR-OLDS AND IT
WILL BE TRIED AS AN ADULT ON
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER CHARGES SHE
WAS BEATEN AND THEN DRAGGED
OUTSIDE AND SOCIETY EXISTS NOT
TO PROTECT 17-YEAR-OLDS WITH
GUNS ON THE MOST BASIC LEVELS,
THOSE ARE THE STRONGEST PEOPLE.
SOCIETY EXISTS TO PROTECT PEOPLE
WHO NEED THE PROTECTION.
THOSE THAT ARE HELPLESS, THOSE
THAT ARE WEAK, THE GRANDMOTHERS
THAT MAY BE DRAGGED AND HAVE
THEIR ARMS RIPPED OFF WITHOUT
POLICE PROTECTION AND IN THE
ABSENCE OF POLICE PROTECTION AND
LEADERSHIP, THOSE ARE EXACTLY
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE MURDERED.
AND IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
NEW ORLEANS.
IF YOU PULL BACK A LITTLE BIT,
IT IS A REALLY CLEAR INDICATION,
THEY HAVE WELL-FUNDED DIVERSION
PROGRAMS FOR AT-RISK YOUTH THAT
ARE SEEING SURGES AND
CARJACKINGS AND COULD THERE BE A
CONNECTION?
LIKE PHILADELPHIA.
REPORTING FOR A LOCAL STATION
THERE, FOX 29.
>> CRIME HAS BEEN EXPLODING AND
THE POLICE NUMBERS HERE, GETTING
WORSE.
A POLICE SOURCE SAYS THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN 757 CARJACKING
CITYWIDE.
THERE WERE ROUGHLY 850
CARJACKINGS IN ALL OF 2021 AND
THE LATEST POLICE STATISTICS
SHOW THE MAJORITY ARE MORE THAN
500 HAPPENED AT GUNPOINT AND
HAPPENED AS THE VICTIMS WERE AT
THEIR PARKED CAR.
>> SO WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
WELL, IT IS HAPPENING FOR A VERY
DEEP REASON, ANY 15 OR
17-YEAR-OLD THAT THREATENS A
LIFE TO STEAL A CAR IS THE
PRODUCT OF SOMETHING THAT IS
VERY HARD TO FIX.
BUT SOCIETY AND THE AUTHORITIES
STILL HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO TRY
TO STOP IT FOR THE SAKE OF THE
REST OF US.
SO WHAT ARE THESE CITIES DOING
TO STOP IT?
WELL, PHILADELPHIA AND AT RISK
YOUTH, THERE IS SOMETHING CALLED
THE PHILADELPHIA PARTNERSHIP.
SO AFTER A MONTH OF VIOLIN
LESSONS, THE YOUNG CRIMINALS,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN BUSTED TOO
MANY TIMES GET THEIR RECORDS
EXPUNGED AND THAT WAS THE PLAN
THAT THE PHILADELPHIA D.A. PUT
INTO PLACE AS OF LAST YEAR.
CRIME HAS GONE UP AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE, CARJACKINGS IN
PARTICULAR.
THE POLICE COMMISSIONER SAID I
DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S
SURPRISING, BUT IT'S DEFINITELY
CONCERNING.
WELL, REALLY.
IT IS FOR SURE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
FROM 2020 UNTIL 2021 THERE'S
BEEN A 108% INCREASE IN
PHILADELPHIA.
CHICAGO HAS HAD MORE THAN A
THOUSAND CARJACKINGS THIS YEAR
ALONE.
SO WHAT DOES THAT DO?
FOR EVERY CARJACKING THERE IS A
MUCH LARGER GROUP OF PEOPLE NOW
AFRAID TO DRIVE.
CHICAGO IS THE PLACE WHERE FOX
RECENTLY IMPLEMENTED THE
JUVENILE INTERVENTION AND
SUPPORT CENTER AND SO THEY
PARTNERED WITH THE BLACK-OWNED
BUSINESSES WHICH PLEDGES TO BE
BOLD IN THE COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH TO PROMOTE NOT HAVING
ANTIRACIST OUTCOMES.
PART OF THAT TO PROTECT
EVERYBODY ELSE.
NOW THE POINT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDES POLITICAL OUTCOMES.
SO HOW DOES THAT WORK IN
CHICAGO?
WELL, HERE IS FOX 32 CHICAGO TO
TELL YOU MORE.
>> ONE OF THE PASSENGERS IN THE
STOLEN SUV EVENTUALLY FLED.
HE WAS 17 YEARS OLD, RELEASED TO
HIS MOTHER.
AND SADLY HE IS NOT THE YOUNGEST
SUSPECT OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
CARJACKING TEAM WERE TOGETHER
AND AN 11-YEAR-OLD WAS ARRESTED
AS PART OF THE CREW AND IT WAS
NOT HIS FIRST TIME.
>> 11 YEARS OLD.
ONE OF THE VICTIMS SAID IT WAS
ALREADY UP TO THE CAR THAT HE
STOLE.
AND HE WILL SOON BE A BIG
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF SOCIETY.
AND HE KNOWS IT'S A JOKE, IT
DOES NOT OVERACHIEVE THE GOAL TO
PROTECT PEOPLE, TO PROTECT
EVERYBODY ELSE THAT WANTS TO GO
TO WORK IN THE MORNING, THOSE
THAT WANT TO TRAVEL ON THE ROADS
WITHOUT BEING KILLED, IT IS SO
IMPORTANT.
THE SAME IS TRUE WITH THE
UNNAMED 16-YEAR-OLD GIRL WHO HAD
HIS CAR HIJACKED WHILE HIS CHILD
WAS IN THE CAR.
HERE IS FOX 32 IN CHICAGO.
>> THE CHILD IS IN THE CAR.
>> A TON OF OTHER CRIMES.
AND IN THIS CASE THEY STOLE
SEVERAL OTHER CARS THAT MONTH.
AND MAYBE THESE PEOPLE REALIZE
THAT IT DOESN'T REALLY WORK, THE
NUCLEAR FAMILY?
WELL, RIGHT.
THOSE THINGS ARE NOT RACIST,
THEY ARE ACTUALLY ESSENTIAL TO
ANY FUNCTIONING CIVILIZATION AND
IN LIEU OF THAT IT IS CLEAR THAT
THINGS DO FALL APART.
AND THE ONLY THING YOU CAN DO IS
TO PUT PEOPLE OUT OF THE PUBLIC
SPHERE AND A WAY SO THAT OTHER
PEOPLE ARE NOT HURT BY THAT.
THAT IS THE BEST THAT WE CAN DO
AS PEOPLE ARE BEING KILLED.
AND IF YOU DON'T DO THAT, YOU
WIND UP WITH A SOCIETY LIKE
THIS.
HERE IS FOX AND DETROIT.
>> ARRESTED AND 11, A
12-YEAR-OLD AND A 14-YEAR-OLD.
>> THEY THINK IT'S FUN, THEY
THINK THERE IS NO PENALTY TO IT
TO MAKE THE HEAD OF THE AUTO
THEFT UNIT, STUNNED OVER THOSE
ARRESTED MONDAY RIGHT HERE ON
THE STORAGE LOT.
THIS KID JUST 14 YEARS OLD AND
ARRESTED THIS WEEKEND, HE WAS
OUT ON BOND AND THEN LAST WEEK
HE HAD CHECKED TWO CARS ON THE
CITY'S EAST SIDE.
>> SO IF YOU LOOK CLOSELY NOT AT
THIS, JUST LOOKING AT THIS ONE,
YOU BEGAN TO UNDERSTAND YOUTH
VIOLENCE PREVENTION INITIATIVES
ARE SUPPOSED TO STOP THIS, THEY
ACTUALLY ENABLE THIS AND THEY
APPEAR TO BE PART OF THE JOE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THE YOUTH DIVERSION PROGRAM THAT
MAKES THIS MORE COMMON HAVE MORE
IN COMMON WITH PEOPLE THAT SEEM
TO ENCOURAGE HOMELESSNESS.
BUT THEY HAVE LED TO MORE
CARJACKING AND HERE IS A REPORT
IN LOS ANGELES.
>> CARJACKING CAUGHT ON CAMERA.
A HOMELESS MAN STOLE HIS BAND.
HE SAID THAT HE HAD EVEN SEEN
HIS ATTACKER AND THAT HE HAD
NEVER HAD THE PROBLEMS, SAYING
THAT HE GAVE THE MAN FOOD
SHORTLY BEFORE PUNCHING HIM IN
THE FACE.
>> SO IF THEY ARE HAPPENING IN
NEW ORLEANS IN LOS ANGELES AND
CHICAGO, OF COURSE, THIS IS
HAPPENING IN OUR BIGGEST CITY,
NEW YORK, WHICH IS ALSO RUN BY
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL, BUT AS
EVIDENCE, NOWHERE IN THE COUNTRY
HAD THEY EXPERIENCED A BIGGER
INCREASE THAN THE BIRTHPLACE OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT IN
MINNEAPOLIS WHERE THIS ALL
STARTED, ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL INSURANCE COMPANY, THE
LARGEST% INCREASE IN THE COUNTRY
IN 2019, 339% JUMP.
WHAT THE HECK I